dalvin cook was gonna hold out unless he
didn't he didn't the report from june
was once he broke off any involvement in
the nf in the vikings virtual offseason
program and he's not showing up for camp
without a reasonable extension well he
hasn't got an extension but he showed up
for camp i think he recognized that
there was a real downside to not showing
up he could still opt out chris we
floated that possibility he could he
could spend the next week
suggesting via his agent that if he's
not comfortable with what he's going to
be making this year maybe he just takes
the year off i don't know what that gets
for him other than
the vikings recognizing they're going to
have to go forward without alexander
madison but we've talked earlier in the
week about this they've got that gary
kubiak kyle shanahan mike shanahan
running system and they just plug in
alexander madison or whoever else if
they don't have dalvin cook but he
showed up
we have that clarity
but we also know he's still not happy
with his contract will the vikings say
hey your contract is what it is you make
1.3 million this year we take it up next
year that's all to be determined uh and
uh it will unfold over the course of the
next week or two i think yeah well it
you know it's again the the the
continuing sad saga of the nfl running
back you know yeah hey yeah you get to
run up the middle for a million dollars
and just get crushed and killed by every
giant human on the planet you know and
oh okay you'll be damaged goods next
year so we'll have to take a little off
of what you ask for next year it's sad
it is i hope they can find a way to
sweeten the pot for him a little bit but
ultimately mike i mean i'm glad to see
him there i think it's the right
approach but mike i really think you're
spot on i i think he realizes whoa we
got a pretty good team
they know how to run block kubiak
understands how to run the football and
i think there's got to be a little fear
in him to go wait if i sit out what is
this alexander madison going to do with
all my carries he might be
he knows how good that kid is he knows
too so he he's probably a little
reluctant to go i don't want to let that
guy have you know 250 carries this year
and maybe you know lead football and
rushing or something that'll totally
devalue me so he's got to be worried
about that and i would think that's in
his head a little bit
you know the vikings loved alvin cook
he's been praised by gm rick spielman
he's been praised by coach mike zimmer
but the reality is that's the position
he plays i remember when ben tate the
former texans running back who was like
a second-round pick out of auburn i
believe he said very candidly after he
took his swings at getting a contract
man if i had to do it all over again i'd
have been a safety i mean we see what's
happened to the running back position in
the nfl and the other reality is this
very rarely does a running back get big
money from a second team if you're going
to get big money it's going to be from
the team that drafted and developed you
and we'll see what the vikings will pay
dalvin cook if anything this year may
have to just get through this year yeah
and take it up next year all right when
we return we're going to take up some
quarterback issues our number one
overall pick is signed aaron rodgers
digging into scab from april patrick
mahomes spending some of that big money
that he got earlier in the month all
that and plenty more as we move into our
number two of pro football talk live on
this wednesday edition rodney harrison
also coming up in about a half hour
we'll be back with more right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports